comme chaque jour désormais on vous
propose de faire un pas de côté
d'analyser comment elle les russes
vivent au quotidien ce conflit c'est
notre chronique vue de russie
avec vous et l'anah volochine bonjour
hélène avoue déjà les images des chaînes
de télévision russes analyse et surtout
comment la propagande russe montre la
guerre en ukraine aujourd'hui oui et
zoom aujourd'hui sur les émissions de
débats ces fameux talk show il y en a
beaucoup sur les chaînes de télévision
russes elles jouent un rôle très
important pour persuader les russes du
fait que vladimir poutine mène une
opération militaire juste on rappelle
qu'on ne parle pas de guerre n'est ce
pas j'ai fait que l'ukraine serait à des
nazis fier du fait aussi que l'occident
serait complice des soi disant crimes
des nazis ukrainien bienvenue dans la
réalité parallèle nous sommes sur rossi
à 1 l'une des deux grandes chaînes de la
télévision publique russe le titre de
l'émission 60 minutes ça dure en réalité
deux heures deux fois par jour c'était
hier il est 11h30 heure de moscou voici
les titres
60 minutes à chaud bonjour chers amis
nous sommes en édition spéciale
on commence avec les infos urgente le
ministère de la défense russe vient de
publier les images du lance missiles de
croisière bastion au travail et du
lancement des missiles de croisière
calibre depuis un bateau de la flotte de
la mer noire voyons çà et là contre des
cibles militaires sur le territoire de
l'ukraine
regardez
alors on s'arrête là j'attire votre
attention sur ces mots que la
présentatrice a particulièrement
accentuée cibles militaires parce que
c'est important à chaque fois que la
télévision russe parle des frappes russe
elle précise qu'il s'agit de cibles
militaires et que la russie ne frappe
donc par par extension jamais des civils
alors regardé après ce titre il ya ces
images de missiles lancés vers des
cibles qu'on ne voit pas un finalement
qui sont très théoriques mais qu'on nous
dit militaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc avec cette musique qui les
accompagnent donc les russes ne voit
jamais finalement ces images qu'on voit
nous deux villes d'ukrainiens de
bombarder ils ne savent pas que les
frappes russe finalement font des
victimes civiles on est donc dans cette
guerre juste dans cette opération
spéciale donnée nazification de
l'ukraine que prétend vladimir poutine
et ces images elles servent aussi à
étaler la puissance et la force de
frappe de la russie est donc à éveiller
un certain sentiment de fierté chez les
russes écoutez justement la reprise de
la présentatrice olga ce cabinet va
après une minute donc de ces images de
frappe sans commentaire juste après les
titres et salam est en extase
ces images sont vraiment vous tente
n'est ce pas et le résultat n'en est pas
moins étourdissant à la quatrième
semaine de l'opération spéciale aux
critères de la russie les forces armées
ukrainiennes et les bataillons de
nationalistes n'ont presque plus d'armes
est presque plus de munitions c'est la
conclusion inquiétante journal
britannique the times selon le journal
l'occident ne s'attendait pas à des
opérations militaires d'une telle
intensité sur le territoire ukrainien et
n'a pas préparé davantage d'armes à
livrer
là c'est une prise de position
finalement assez surréaliste elena ça
mérite quand même que vous reveniez
dessus oui explication de texte parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses dans cet
extrait d'abord on est dans le registre
de l'émotion des images envoûtantes un
résultat étourdissant nous dit la
présentatrice il s'agit toujours pour la
propagande russe de faire adhérer les
russes par l'affect aux actions de
bladinières poutine est d'ailleurs on va
le voir peut-être cette image du z qui
apparaît sur le sud sous les pieds de la
présentatrice sur le plateau donc un
message subliminal c'est le symbole de
cette opération le z qui figure sur les
tanks russes de ce soutien aussi je
suppose et imaginer des rues sales
opérations de poutine et quand on parle
d'ailleurs souvent parlant d'affect au
russe de vladimir poutine ils disent
qu'ils l'aiment qu'il admire pour sa
force sa masculinité cette force de
frappe justement on n'est pas du tout
dans le registre de la rationalité parce
que finalement rien ne vint aujourd'hui
dans la vie des russes mais c'est pour
ça c'est parce que la propagande éveil
justement c'est sentiment très profond
irrationnel de l'ordre de l'amour ça
nous paraît à nous complètement
irrationnel et un dessin de s'extasier
devant ce qui nous apparaît à nous comme
l'horreur de la guerre mais ça parle
russe qui regardent la télévision parce
qu'on est dans une guerre propre on ne
voit pas la destruction ne voit pas les
victimes causées par ces missiles on est
dans une guerre juste et c'est aussi le
sens et c'est important de le souligner
non seulement de la propagande mais
aussi des manuels d'histoire qui ont été
écrits avec une russie qui a toujours le
bon rôle dans les guerres l'autre partie
de ce message qu'on a entendu elena
c'est que les ukrainiens seraient en
train de perdre la guerre oui dans cet
extrait c'est ce qui est dit la russie
mais non seulement une guerre propre
mais une guerre victorieuse c'est
l'autre message très important à faire
passer aux russes deuxième partie de cet
extrait je rappelle la présentatrice dit
les forces armées ukrainiennes et les
bataillons nationalistes n'ont presque
plus d'armée presque plus de munitions
selon le journal times peu importe la
réalité du terrain ce convoi nous
aujourd'hui avec une armée russe en
difficulté et qui patine c'est ce
qu'affirme la présentatrice alors on est
allé voir par esprit de rigueur regarder
justement le site du journal times et la
première arctique en ligne le ministère
de la défense britannique nous dit que
les troupes russes démoralisé pourrait
être encerclée autour de kiev donc
exactement l'inversé de ce que prétend
la télévision russes en citant la presse
britannique mais peu importe parce que
la propagande c'est que les russes
n'iront pas vérifié ces ressources est
d'autant plus qu'elles sont en langue
anglaise et cette réalité inverse
prétend aussi que ce ne sont pas les les
russes qui sont responsables de cette
guerre oui une guerre propre une guerre
juste une guerre victorieuse mais une
guerre dont on ne voulait pas et on
revient à l'ennemi originel j'ai
remarqué que depuis deux jours la
propagande russe prépare l'opinion à la
visite de joe biden au sommet de l'otan
à bruxelles et là il s'agit de remettre
à l'ordre du jour est au premier plan ce
message apparu dès 2014 la révolution de
maidan en ukraine comme quoi ce serait
les états unis qui aurait provoqué cette
révolution suite provoqué la guerre en
ukraine en menaçant la russie écoutez
c'est tout cet autre extrait
le conseiller à la sécurité nationale de
by john sullivan a prévenu aujourd'hui
les ukrainiens qu'ils devraient
s'attendre je cite à des jours très
difficiles et que pour l'ukraine la
guerre ne se termineraient ni facilement
ni rapidement
donc les états unis ont quand même
décidé de se battre avec l'art jusqu'au
tout dernier ukrainien
remarquer que des américains ne fit même
pas un mot sur une solution pacifique au
conflit comme dans orwell la guerre
c'est la paix la liberté cet esclavage
l'ignorance c'est la force
on est finalement elena vraiment dans
une réalité parallèle oui la guerre
c'est la paix c'est cette réalité
orwellienne qu'on ressent quand on vit
en russie et dont on accuse vladimir
poutine finalement qui attaque et
l'ukraine en prétendant se défendre de
la menace de l'otan mais peu importe
pour la propagande russe de qui a
attaqué elle prétend que ce sont les
états unis qui veulent la guerre ce sont
eux qui font la guerre et
et on le rappelle états unis n'auraient
quand même c'est important de le dire
n'ont même pas voulu instaurer une no
fly zone au dessus de l'ukraine
justement pour éviter tout conflit avec
la russie mais peu importe cette réalité
qu'on connaît nous selon la propagande
des états unis voudraient sacrifier
l'ukraine jusqu'au dernier ukrainiens
nous dit la propagande russe la question
qu'on se pose tous évidemment ici est ce
que les russes y croit alors je
terminerais là dessus et je ferai
régulièrement des points sur l'opinion
parce que ça c'est très important c est
ce que cette propagande fonctionne et
bien avec toutes les précautions qu'il
faut mettre dans la lecture des sondages
d'opinion d'un pays autoritaires sinon
dictatorial aujourd'hui comme l'est la
russie 79 6% de cote de confiance selon
l'institut vtsiom à vladimir poutine
c'était le 13 mars 2022
merci vous pouvez à vau-l'eau chine et
cette chronique